questions for you actually the first one
is you've been tweeting you've been
hinting are you joining Ben Higgins on
tour no that's not it I'm not joining
that Kagan's on tour it is a way that
fans are going to be able to take in and
digest and get all the behind-the-scenes
goodies about each episode with people
from the episode soon after it happens
you're doing an after-show you're
hosting and see what it is you are meant
to do that you are gonna be great I'm
supposed to be and I don't want to say I
will because things can happen but as of
now I'm supposed to be at the live
taping on Monday yeah I've seen it yeah
yeah I'm excited but I'm nervous I
haven't been on like a bachelor thing in
10 years since I was on the show 2010
like your season was one of the first
where we saw you really take control and
have those hard conversations and now
with Hannah season I'm very curious what
you make them especially like the Luke
stuff the JED stuff like what it would
here
I need the Allie lowdown well the loop
stuff is hard because Luke is a
manipulator
Luke is toxic he's an abuser honestly um
but he's a human and the way we saw him
treated at the men tell all was not fair
I think the way that Conor swore at him
and called him a psychopath hurt people
hurt people so just because somebody
bully is that doesn't mean you bully
back that doesn't make it okay honestly
I feel like you know we have seen some
pretty tragic things come out of the
bachelor community world and I think we
need to think about people's feelings
and you know I just think that the guy
is should have pumped the brakes a
little bit do you worry about that you
think about that and like the mental
health of it all but the mental health
of the contestants for sure it's I mean
for instance this new top secret
bachelor thing I'm doing that's we're
announcing it's top secret it's not top
secret I don't know why he'd say that
but it's really exciting I myself I'm
like oh my gosh in this little way I'm
putting myself back out there to be
judged and poke that and it takes a toll
on my own mounted mental health so yeah
I think about can you imagine being him
I'm not saying that Luke did the right
thing Luke is a jerk okay but can you
imagine being in his shoes at that
mental waffle can you imagine that he's
getting on the internet the comments
section and you look what people are
saying I totally understand what being
and just because he's done awful things
and hurt people that doesn't give us the
excuse to hurt him back
it's what I'm saying you know hurt
people hurt people something's going on
inside him that makes him that way how
do you think Hanna's handled everything
and I feel like Luke really did put her
on the spot though and kind of forced
her to share more about her sex life in
her personal life than maybe she had
intended going into it what do you think
about that I think it was a fair
question to ask if you're about to get
engaged to somebody and you want to know
hey did you just have sex with somebody
else I think that's a fair question to
ask I think it's how he asked it that
was inappropriate you know he made it
seem like something she did was wrong
and I don't think I don't think she did
anything wrong he had the right to ask
the question but she's she can you have
sex with more than one person in a week
yes you can can you in the Bachelorette
absolutely so you know I don't fault her
but I don't fault him for asking the
question it's how he did it but you know
he yeah he just didn't throw away have
you seen the finale
because I have what happened are we
gonna be shocked how how are we gonna
feel it is unlike any finale there is
ever been and that's the truth I know
Chris Harrison says in every season the
most dramatic episode ever
and I'm like Chris come on this is like
so not and sometimes it is sometimes
it's not
last season with Colton I thought oh we
can't get more dramatic than this
I think this finale might top that one
out why do you say that because it does
not end the way it normally does how our
fans gonna feel yeah I think fans oh
gosh I don't know I can't answer that I
can't do it away would you say there's a
happy ending of sorts
I cannot answer that question no I can't
wait for Monday now I'm excited actually
it's gonna be good it's gonna be yeah
and I and I you know actually yes if I
what I thought about hand I sigh hand
has grown a lot this season I think
she's young I was very young when I was
a bachelor I made some questionable
choices or did some questionable things
I think she did a lot of things I was
very critical of this season to be
honest like what um like making it seem
like it's the journey is just about her
and not the others like she a lot of
times she would say this is you know
this is my journey this isn't about you
but it's about if both people in a
relationship so I think that some things
you know I didn't really agree with but
I always supported her even when I
disagreed with her and I think you as
you grew a lot so yeah about you because
your little one just turned 3 so you now
have two kids under the ages of three
that's crazy it's how are you it's a
couple hours ago because my hair was out
to here I mean I have my zit covered
right now but massive Reds at my chin
have is it oh my gosh I do bags under my
eyes and I'm like I am so tired it is
like this how because it's been such a
crazy month for me and then two hours
later I'm like glam but like literally
on the way here like are getting ready
you know Mike Suns crying I'm holding
him while he's eating a banana and
pushing it against my makeup and I'm
like like it's it's chaos before this
it's nice I mean I threw this this house
is like insane
97 million dollars you know it's for
sale you want to buy it you're gonna go
in slit see maybe I can afford like a
light bulb game like maybe like one
block of that brick over there tell us
that you and Kevin were really working
on the marriage and that you guys
weren't sleeping in the same bed because
you were just so tired how are things
with you guys great like I
you wouldn't wonder what are you gonna
find your marriage again when you gonna
find it like oh wait I like you like we
actually like each other and we get
along and we like to go on dates and
we're like I think you're sexy and
you're think I'm like so yes things are
like we're we're we're supposed to be
[Music]